And now, for our final section on the interface, let's go over variables.
You'll be able to find the variables section down here in the bottom left-hand corner.
Now, variables are just an area in memory which has been allocated to save something.
Now, the thing that can be saved to it can be a lot of different things.
At the moment, we have three variables down here in the bottom left-hand corner,
and they are all references, as shown by blue,
and they're references to the components that we already have within our actor.
Now, if I push plus, this is going to create a new variable, and this is of type Boudia.
Now, if we come into the top right-hand corner, we can see here that we've got the details.
The first thing is we've got the name. This can be anything.
And under that, we have variable type.
If we do the drop down from the variable type, we're going to see a number of different options.
The first one we have here is a Boolean, and we talked about this before.
This is either zero or one, and this is usually used to denote true or false.
And now, below that, we have four green variables.
Now, all of the green ones are numeric.
So the main ones that you're going to encounter are the integer, which is a whole number.
So that could be one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
It just cannot have any decimal points.
The float, however, can have as many decimal points as you want.
It can be quite a large number, but it takes off a little bit more memory when using it.
Below this, we have these ones in purple and pink.
These are all text-based.
Now, we'd usually use string is probably the most common one of these we'd be using.
Below this, we have vector, rotator and transform.
These are all variables which are often used when working with 3D space.
The vector is three different float variables that would dictate a value in x, y and z.
So it could be used to pinpoint a location in space.
A rotator, again, is three float variables.
However, it has got some extra functionality around working in degrees.
A transform is actually a struct of three different vectors,
a one for location, rotation and scale.
Now, that's not all.
We also have a ton of other variables that are available to us,
and these can be numerous different things.
One of the things that we very often use is references.
So say I wanted a reference to an actor.
I could just type in actor, and we'll be able to see here
we can have an object reference to a specific actor in blue.
In this case, I'm just going to use a transform
so that we can look into this a bit more.
Now, the first thing is we do have a setting for default value
down here in the bottom right hand corner.
You cannot set this until we have actually gone away and compiled.
So you can see now that I've compiled this, I can go in here,
and I've got my three different locations, and I can set this,
and then that's going to be the default value that is set
at the beginning when any of these are created.
So let's look at how a variable will be used within the event graph.
Now, if I come down and grab one of the variables
and drag it into the C, and then just left-hand click to drop it,
you're going to see that we get two different options, a GET or a SET.
Now, what these are is a GET will return the value
which is stored within the variable, and a SET is going to overwrite the value
which is in that variable.
So a GET is going to return the value, and a SET is going to change it.
So if I select GET, you'll see that I've now got a node here,
which on the right hand side has an output pin
that is going to provide us with a transform.
Now, if I drag one in again, and this time use SET,
you're going to see that we have an execution pin.
That's because we're not just querying this, we're actually going to change it.
So there is an action that's going to be done,
and that needs to be done at a certain time and a certain place.
So we'll need to have an input, and we have an output pin accordingly.
Now, what we plug into this right-hand side is going to be what is overwritten.
What comes out of the left-hand side, what comes out of the right-hand side
is going to be the value, the end value.
Now, there is a quicker way to bring these in.
I just delete these ones here.
If I was to drag in a new file, and if I was to hold down the CTRL key when I drop it,
it's automatically going to give us a GET.
If I drag it in and hold down the ALT key,
it's going to automatically give us a SET.
Now, there is another thing.
Because this is a struct, we are going to be capable of right-hand clicking,
and we've got an option to split the struct pin.
What that's going to do is it's going to break it down
so that we can now have a pin for each one of the three vectors.
So location, rotation, and scale.
We can do this on the opposite end as well.
Split the stroke pin.
And that's useful if you only want to get hold of the location, for example, or rotation.
And we can even split this further into the pure floats.
So I could split them.
If I just wanted to get the Z location, which would show us how high up
this transform is in the world, then I can access just that float.
And this is common in lots of other modes as well.
If I was to grab a trace, the line traced by channel,
you can see here on the right-hand side, I have an OUT hit, which is a struct.
And if I right-hand click on that and split that struct pin,
you're going to get a lot more information.
So be aware that you can do that at any one point.
You can also right-hand click and go re-combine struct pins
if you want to re-combine them.
If you ever need to create a variable, there is one other option as well.
Say, for example, in this case, I wanted to save the OUT hit actor.
Now, a quick way that I can do this is I could right-hand click on the output pin
and go Promote to Variable.
And that will automatically create the variable which could contain this value.
And this is quite useful because you sometimes might be confused
what variable type you are working with.
But if you do it this way, you're going to know that that's going to connect up correctly.
So that is variables.
We'll be playing with these a bit more when we jump into the exercise.
But just be aware of how they work.